salud en directo América de Francia 24
como siempre Todas las mañanas nos
acompaña en nuestro estudio para hablar
de salud más Romero sala mar bienvenida
empezamos con un estudio revolucionario
sobre las neuronas y el cerebro Sierra
hoy es uno de esos días en que parece
que estamos hablando de una película
pero no es la realidad es el experimento
que hicieron unos científicos de la
Universidad de Stanford publicado en la
revista nature básicamente el titular es
que consiste en que injertaron unas
neuronas humanas en el cerebro de ratas
y lograron que participaran en los
circuitos neuronales de los animales
echemos un vistazo al paso a paso de
este experimento primero que hicieron
agarraron las células de la piel no de
las personas pues que iban a utilizar
sus neuronas estas células las hicieron
como rebobinar digamos hasta su estado
embrionario se ha estado en el que
pueden convertirse en células de
cualquier órgano de cualquier tejido las
convirtieron en neuronas y crearon algo
que se llaman unos organoides de son
unas bolitas de poco más de un milímetro
dos milímetros con un millón de células
un millón de neuronas algo que es muy
poco teniendo en cuenta que el cerebro
tiene unas 86.000 millones de neuronas
no entonces son esos pequeños órganoides
mini cerebros digamos no luego los
implantaron en el cerebro de las ratas y
cinco meses después vieron Pues que
estaba pasando no esta ratas además por
cierto están pues se le suprimió
modificar las genéticamente para que no
tengan sistema inmune y no puedan
rechazar este injerto y vieron que
efectivamente estas neuronas estaban
pues integradas como decíamos en los
circuitos neuronales y que recibían los
inputs sensoriales del exterior no les
hicieron por ejemplo como mover Los
Bigotes y sentían y vieron que se
activaban estos órganoides que habían
implantado Por qué es tan importante
este experimento y que busca no a un
futuro claro Más allá de lo fascinante
que resulta esto esto tiene una utilidad
o muy muy real No ya que viene el plot
twist del giro de guión no solo hicieron
estos organoides con células de personas
sanas sino que también usaron células de
personas que tienen el síndrome de
Timothy o de Timoteo que es una
enfermedad congénita que tiene problemas
neurológicos y pudieron observar no las
diferencias entre los organoides y cómo
se cómo se participaban los de las
personas sanas y los de las personas con
este síndrome pudieron ver las
diferencias ya en estas etapas tan
primarias en las construcciones de
circuitos neuronales esto supone un
salto revolucionario porque significa
que ahora existe esta metodología y que
esto se puede hacer tanto con los
organoides pues perdón con las
enfermedades como este síndrome como con
la esquizofrenia por ejemplo la
epilepsia o incluso el autismo no es la
primera vez que esto se puede observar
no solo en el exterior como en vitro no
en el laboratorio sino en células que
participan activamente de un organismo
vivo entonces Esas digamos la gran
diferencia y lo resumía muy bien no una
una aquí tenemos la reacción de Luis
montoliu que es un amplio tecnólogo que
recogió pues su opinión en Science media
Center en España básicamente plantea eso
no es un experimento sorprendente un
avance significativo un estudio muy
completo pero que también abre la puerta
a cómo Qué pasará con la bioética de
todo esto no cómo Tendremos que
considerar pues estas cerebros híbridos
de neuronas de una especie de otra
increíble mar Pero vamos con otro avance
científico esta vez en España si
hablamos del primer trasplante de
intestino de una persona fallecida a una
persona Viva en todo el mundo nunca se
había hecho antes y lo recibió en este
caso una niña de 13 meses en un hospital
de Madrid en el hospital Público de la
paz no tenía un fallo intestinal
diagnosticado desde el primer mes de
vida y tenía el estado de salud muy
deteriorado eso la hizo pues candidata
para este trasplante y además se creía
que La donación de personas fallecidas
donaciones sistólica se llama de este
órgano en concreto del intestino era muy
difícil porque una vez te mueres los
órganos dejan de recibir oxigenación y
algunos se pueden deteriorar muy
rápidamente como es el caso del
intestino se había probado con otros
órganos que sí se logra ya pero con este
en particular Entonces pues por eso no
tres años de investigación dieron estos
frutos se logró mantener este órgano
digamos en buen estado vivo fuera del
cuerpo para que lo recibiera esta niña
para que no se deteriorara o algo que es
un gran avance una gran noticia para la
familia de Emma de la bebé de 13 meses
pero también pues para toda la comunidad
científica Porque si se ha hecho una vez
significa que se puede hacer muchas
veces escuchemos
Emma presentaba una enfermedad que se
llama fracaso intestinal o fallo
intestinal eso qué significa significa
que por un problema por una enfermedad
su intestino no es capaz de absorber la
energía los alimentos que necesita para
crecer y vivir normalmente a por sus
características y sus complicaciones
hacían necesario realizar este
trasplante que en el caso de Emma es un
trasplante multivisteral a día de hoy
Cómo se puede ver Enma está bien muy
bien para la salud de mano me imagino la
felicidad de los papás y nosotros
estamos felices por ella los acompañamos
con una pandemia covid 19 de mar porque
no se ha terminado y la luz verde para
vacunas a bivalentes para niños en
Estados Unidos Así es no se ha terminado
tampoco se ha terminado la investigación
y los avances para combatir esta
pandemia no es la vacuna de moderna y de
pfizer para mayores de 6 años en el
primer caso mayores de 5 años en el caso
de pfizer ya se habían aprobado en
adultos por ejemplo en América Latina
también ya se están aplicando en el pero
para niños pues es la primera vez pero
hablemos bien En qué consisten estas
vacunas bivalentes porque parece que
hayamos dejado un poco de lado este tema
pero aquí seguimos informando sobre
estos avances no básicamente es tan
sencillo como que la vacuna monovalente
es la que conocíamos hasta ahora la que
nos hemos aplicado simplemente tiene
partes de la variante original del virus
del 19 para que el cuerpo reaccione y
despierte el sistema inmune contra esta
variante en cambio la bivalente mantiene
tanto la variante original como partes
de las variantes de un micron ve A4 Y
ba5 eso significa Pues que da inmunidad
contra ambas variantes contra la
variante original y contra la omicron
que es pues la más extendida hoy en día
y que pues favorece esta protección y
este inmunidad es la única diferencia no
ha causado algo de recelo de que no haya
habido un proceso de estudio tan largo
como ha habido antes con las pues las
primeras vacunas no las primeras
versiones de estas vacunas Pero esto en
realidad es importante recordar que se
hace todo el tiempo con las vacunas de
la gripe también se aprobó Pues la
primera no la base y luego estas
modificaciones no se considera que
tengan que estudiarse tan a fondo Así
que parte de seguridad todo está bien
estas vacunas son seguras igual que las
primeras que salieron otra buena noticia
en la lucha contra el 19 de mar
Muchísimas gracias como siempre mañana
más salud como siempre